une élection boudé par les congolais ils
étaient peu nombreux ce dimanche à
s'être déplacés pour choisir le prochain
président de la république dans certains
bureaux de vote le taux de participation
atteignait à peine les 10 % à la
fermeture une abstention qui n'a pas
empêché le président denis sassou
n'guesso de se féliciter du processus
électoral
juste
démontrant ses
qui ne se présume pas
pourtant plusieurs irrégularités ont bel
et bien été constaté à brazzaville les
représentants du parti congolais du
travail au pouvoir était souvent les
seuls délégués politiques présents dans
les bureaux de vote des électeurs se
sont également plaints de ne pas voir
leur nom figurer sur les listes
électorales d'autres n'ont tout
simplement pas reçu leur carte
d'électeur des irrégularités dénoncées
par les candidats de l'opposition
mes impressions dans ce but le voit pas
beaucoup de gens qui viennent ne sais
pas pourquoi ça traîne est due aux
conditions la bise le secteur j'ai
constaté que dans là tout le secteur les
gens n'ont pas eu les cartes d'électeur
une opposition dont le meilleur espoir
vient de s'éteindre diagnostiqué
vendredi positif au coronavirus guy
brice parfait kolélas ce est décédé à
bord de l'avion médicalisé qui l'évacuer
vers la france avant sa mort il avait
appelé ses sympathisants à voter en
masse
chers compatriotes sur une difficulté
je me bats contre l'amour mais cependant
je vous demande de vous lever
allez-y voté pour le changement
je me serais pas battus pour y mater
vous et les vagues de l'ain venez de
vous au mas dieu merci
les premiers résultats du scrutin ne
devraient être connus que dans le
courant de la semaine
en attendant le réseau internet a été
coupé dans tout le pays
aucun incident n'a été déploré le
maintien au pouvoir de denis sassou
n'guesso devrait lui être assurée après
déjà trente six années à la tête de
l'état congolais en 2016 sa réélection
contestée avait entraîné une violente
révolte dans le sud est du pays